good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Thursday that feels like a
Friday because we're celebrating
we're celebrating
ass white ass assho
ex excuse me this is a nice
familyfriendly podcast and people listen
in the car with their kids and I'm not
going to tolerate that type of language
so early on in the show when the kids
are still awake I'm not going to do it
oh my God okay Mom yeah teacher classes
in session ooh ooh Order in the Court
Order in the Court if you're watching on
YouTube It's A Feast for the eyes today
because chy and I are wearing new merch
that drops tomorrow morning and not only
are we wearing this gorgeous new merch
but we're kind of twinning with our
updos and just like slaying the house
down Boots the Cozy Vibes the Cozy Vibes
and this is our new collection that
drops tomorrow so tomorrow morning at
10: a.m. eastern time at shop toast
merch.com you can get this groutfit
sport
set that we're sporting and we also for
the Super Bowl we also have a Navy crew
neck sweatpant set that just says the
toast on the
breast dude girlies yeah so the two sets
are kind of like inverted versions of
one another though not identical but the
other set is just Navy and it's it's a
little more paired down while this is
very toasty can I ask you a
question do you think two people on the
planet love anything more than we love
the time 10:00 a.m. like one thing about
us like if we're going to do something
it's at 10:00 a.m. no 10:00 a.m. is the
right time it's the it's a good time
even with the kids like 10:00 a.m. is
the right like we left for Disney let's
get out the door at 10:00 a.m. like it's
a very realistic time it's not too early
it's not too late all you need is a
light jacket right it's like the first
double digit hour of the day so it's
like early but like a little late yeah
it's not like early bird gets the worm
right right it's not noon I've been
doing early bird gets the worm I've been
waking up every day at like 6:30 7 which
is earlier than I wake up I think it's
because I was on like a prazone pack and
you know they make you a little like
it's a steroid you're it up yeah I
actually took my so that's why you've
been a little Nutty Professor
okay you said it was Tylenol you were
taking well I started the swirly was on
roids but Jackie the day that I everyone
thought I was on drugs and like High I
actually hadn't started the roids yet oh
wow I feel like on this show like when
you are on any sort of medication
substance you have to let everyone know
because they're so attuned to our
personalities that when there's even the
slightest change like you you have to be
transparent about what you're taking
unlike Tristan Thompson yes which we
will talk about today I wasn't planning
on it but oh you know what I'm so glad
cuz I don't give a but now that
we've brought it up let's just deliver
the news I don't know I'm sure everyone
already saw he's been suspended because
they drug test you in the NBA for like
roids real roids yeah and he tested
negative oh no excuse me he it was a
negative it was alad it was aladine he
tested positive which was very negative
for
him is that from something I just made
it up that's
hysterical oh hysterical stuff might
even be like better than is alad alad
okay what is better than someone asking
like what's that from to something you
just orig that's like someone saying did
you get your Glam done and you did
yourself so true also even though Co was
like a really dark time in like our
history one of the bright spots was
taking a covid test and telling people
your
Co and telling people your Co aladine
yeah like we'd be like I think I have it
I think I have it and then we'd send the
thing and people would be like would you
what do you what you have it it's
aladine and they didn't know if you were
positive or negative if you guys don't
know that reference from the dictator
staring Sasha Baron Cohen like I do feel
sorry for you I want to say I feel like
people actually don't know that
reference that's like not one of his
most quoted or popular movies obviously
everybody knows Borat but the dictator
Aladin is so grossly and
criminally underrated criminally like
you need toast movie of the week you
guys have to watch the dictator at some
point this week it's it's probably not
better than Borat because Borat was a
cultural shift but it's his number
movie wait I feel like we're confusing
movies what is the Seth Rogan movie that
like
oh that supreme leader um I think inter
no that's the interview interview okay
they're both like Loosely based off Kim
Jong we need to talk about something
that I feel like gets swept under the
rug and we need answers remember when
that movie was coming out the interview
and it was like making fun of Kim
Jong-un and so all of these emails
started to leak from Sony and there was
a hack they said it was like North Korea
retaliating against the coming out of
this Seth Rogan movie yeah yeah was that
true was it not it was my understanding
that like that was the that was that's
like the the line we've been served but
like that seems insane do you feel like
there's a conspiracy beneath the surface
about that leak I kind of do like it
really doesn't make sense that it is a
little radical it is a little radal
leaked the emails because he didn't want
this unflattering movie to come out
about him I know I and it's not even a
movie about him like it's a parody
movie yeah and there's like actual like
documentary about Kim Jun that are like
based on real stuff that happened that
like are probably worse right right and
this like was kind of like funny and I
think he came off he listens to Firework
by Katie Perry like you got to see a
different side of Kim actually I just
saw a video of Kim um there was like a
big Affair in North Korea they um threw
a volleyball game in his honor I guess
he like loves volleyball do you know
what I'm talking about did you see this
no but it's reminding me of one of my
favorite memes that I'm going to go find
but so he showed up they they threw this
like recreational volleyball game for
him where like all these volleyball
players came and like there was
cheerleaders and Kim Jong sat and just
like had the best time watching these
men play volleyball that's classic Kim
Classic Kim there is a meme that I send
to Ben every time I see it and I am
going to take the time to find it if you
don't mind no I don't mind and I do feel
like now would be a good time to mention
like Kim Jong-un ill and the dictators
of North Korea like is one of my
favorite topics to talk about it's it is
lowkey one of the craziest things about
like the world we currently live in like
that there's like this kind of like
toxic remote dictatorship and like we
don't even know what goes on there they
don't have cellones they're completely
cut off it really is the craziest thing
and there's that girl you know the girl
I'm talking about uh
Crystal she's she escaped yeah she like
escaped North Korea and like that's her
thing now she's like a media personality
I saw some I've always see clips of her
on Joe Roger like talking about it it
sounds like not fun she has a book and
Rebecca's read it and she's always
recommending it to us to read on the
redheads maybe we should tury like and
know what we're talking about I feel as
though my Roman Empire is the fact that
North Korea exists like it's so crazy
and it's just so opposite from our way
of life you know freedom I won't let you
die freedom I will not give you up you
know those liberties we take for granted
it's so true ah makes you think you're
having a hard time finding this
meme
according to his biography Kim Jong ill
first picked up a golf club in 1994 at
North Korea's only golf course and shot
a 38 underpar round that included no
fewer than 11 holes in one that's really
funny satisfied with his performance he
reportedly immediately declared his
retirement from the sport that is so
funny and that's literally been if he
was a dictator like literally mine would
be starting propaganda that he hit 11
holes in one in one game yeah but like
the fact that that all of the subjects
like have to think Kim Jong is like the
most amazing thing ever even though he's
like literally never done or
accomplished anything and he's like kind
of ugly very ugly um if people just like
adored me like it would be mandatory
every Friday night like there's a tury
concert at MSG and you better like light
your phones up and get lit yeah
it's also crazy how the transition from
ill to O Kim jong's like so smooth
Jackie I'm so glad you brought that up
because I actually remember I'm
literally gonna start crying it's so
funny I like remember being like 12 when
Kim Jong-il died and like I knew his
name in my bones Kim Jong Kim Jong-il
Kim and I said there's no way I'm going
to be able to start saying Kim Jong-un
it's just it's beyond my capability like
it's a it's a rebranding that's going to
take a while to get used to so seamless
the way I don't even even think about
Kim Jong ill anymore it's crazy cuz for
a while the name on everybody's lips was
Kim Jong Gill and now it's O exclusively
un exclusively o you forgot about the
ill and I do think that like branding
agencies should looked to what they've
done so how you could change the names
culturally so easily I completely
agree and it just like it does make me
sad like obviously on a really serious
note like living in North Korea sounds
like really one of the most miserable
existences of all
time and even made like making it even
more sad as they can't listen to the
toast no that's Devastation that would
be like in my in my dictatorship that
would be mandatory of course we would be
playing over the loudspeakers yeah we we
would literally be like um Stanley Tucci
in The Hunger Games Caesar Milan yeah
yeah not Milan not Milan Caesar Milan is
a celebrity dog trainer who we had on
the breath once but back to what I was
saying about the interview and the Sony
hacking like were they
really like that's insane if true and if
not true they used the hacking as like a
marketing gimmick for a movie about
dictator I guess kind of smart but these
like crazy emails came out remember like
Kevin Hartwood and promote his own movie
I that is my Roman Empire for real like
honestly CU When I saw it I was like
damn and then the more I thought about
it I'm like no this is a special breed
of businessman and I completely agree
yeah like I don't own this movie you do
yes I'm being paid to do it and it would
behoove me to promote it but this is a
part of the job no I remember reading
those emails and like my whole
perspective on life changed like a crazy
time and they said it was all because of
a movie and I just I'm going to need
more and then they still released the
movie cuz of course like you can't give
in to Kim right we don't negotiate the
movie was like you could only get it at
home it wasn't in theaters it was crazy
that was a crazy time we started this
conversation
aladine to the interview Tristan Tristan
Tristan was positive which was negative
news for him oh so I was saying that
when we ever take medication we're like
athletes and the world to
know yeah so clud is on steroids period
I'm on steroids and I usually yesterday
I took them after the toast because I
don't like the way they make me like my
face really hot and then I like speed up
for like 20 minutes um so if I get a
little nuts I'm not feeling it yet if I
get a little nuts it's it's the Zone
prna Zone she's Ro it up she's juic up
yeah don't drug test me I'll fail that
and my poppy seed bagel I have this week
I'm going to fail
she's a failure which is positive news
for
her she's no it's actually negative news
for me aladine still yeah he was kind of
on to something it's confusing positive
negative no it's the premise of the joke
aladine is pure Brilliance like oh like
I literally this week I got a strep test
so like it came back negative I'm like
but it's positive it really is
negative for strep which was positive
positive for
me damn confusing confusing so we've got
a great show today we've got new merch
launching tomorrow which is so exciting
if you have any questions I'm wearing a
size medium I I think I feel like this
particular set should be the standard
for sizing I love the sample that we use
like this is a size medium I feel like
it fits me perfectly yeah this is a size
TI at all I'm wearing a size large and I
could go for a medium it's it's very
baggy on me so I do feel like you should
be true to size and if you're true to
your size it will be a little oversized
exactly this is my size it's it's giving
me room to breathe I'm not tight
anywhere but it doesn't feel so big yeah
so I'm wearing medium I think just do
your regular size um so that's exciting
today's also our last in studio show of
the week tomorrow there is an episode
but after this episode I'm heading to
the South heading down south to the land
of the pans you know and I'm headed to
the rodeo which I'm so excited about so
hopefully I'll see the Fort Worth
toaster out and about you know hustling
the Stockyards at the Stockyards and
then I'm racing home Sunday to see the
ners play and it's just so it's going to
be a great weekend even though like
tomorrow it's not even Friday but um
looking forward to the weekend because
you're looking ahead you're an optimist
yeah exactly I have hope ha Tia I have
hope exactly great well I think we pl oh
do I have plans this weekend you know
the usual fun T kids trout football
barbecue trout trout
skin trout skin killer will be reliving
our weekend maybe see some friends it'll
just be a nice home weekend after our
big Extravaganza you need to decompress
you need this yeah maybe a little
sleeping in if the kids will let good
luck we'll see you never know it happens
every once in a while maybe it could
fall on a Sunday do you wake up in like
a panic no cuz I'll never forget like
the first time I went to visit Olivia
when she had moved down um to Florida
Shapiro was going on a business trip so
I came to stay with her and like the
third night I was there we slept
together in the same bed cuz I was like
a little freaking freaked out of being
in the house alone I think Olivia was
too she was new to being a homeowner and
I woke up at like 10: and Kayla must
have been like 1 one and a half and
Olivia was still in bed with me and we
were freaking she was like oh she woke
up in such a tizzy Kayla was still
sleeping beautiful isn't that crazy M
crazy
Kayla so now without further Ado here
are the fast SI stories that you need to
know and the fast five stories that you
need to know are brought to you by
current old school banking just is not
working anymore they ding you with
ridiculous fees they play games with
your money and they want you to get into
debt so stop banking old and get current
the future of banking current is banking
and credit building together they make
it easy to get paid as soon as possible
build credit safely and save more all in
one app managing your money can be hard
but current makes it easy you set up
direct deposits to get the most out of
current you get paid up to two days
faster you can qualify for fee free
overdraft up to $200 when you spend more
than you've got we've all done that
before but current's got your back get
their awesome looking build cards that's
like nothing else out there you can
build credit safely using your own money
so you don't pile on debt there are no
credit checks so anyone can start
building credit right now with current I
love that this is a Forward Thinking
company like we need to start building
credit I I feel like I started building
credit too young like for so long I just
had like a debit card and it's really
just not like a smart way if you want to
like be financially healthy buy a home
one day so possibly the best part about
current is that there's no annual or
minimum balance fees so what are you
waiting for get current the future of
banking go to current.com toast or
download the app that's C nt.com
toast terms apply current is a financial
technology company not a bank banking
services provided by choice financial
group member FDIC and crossover Bank
member FDIC for full terms and
conditions visit current.com or call 888
85117 2 for more information today's
episode is also brought to you by better
help around the new year we get obsessed
with changing ourselves instead of just
expanding on what we already are doing
right maybe you finally organize one
part of your space and you want to
tackle another maybe you're taking your
supplements every morning and now you
actually want to eat breakfast too well
therapy will help you find your
strengths so you can ditch the extreme
resolutions and make changes that will
really stick and that are built to last
so if you've been thinking of giving
therapy a try or you've been thinking
about getting back into therapy if you
used to do it why don't you give better
help a try it's done entirely online
it's designed to be convenient flexible
and suited to your schedule just fill
out a brief questionnaire to get match
with licensed therapist and switch
therapists any time for no additional
charge what's so great about better help
is it's super accessible so you can get
match with a therapist if it's not the
right match the first time around which
is super super common and not a big deal
they make it so easy to change it up
they'll just match you with someone else
it's not awkward in person if you like
meet someone and then you have to like
cancel and call and wait in the office
it's so awkward better help gets rid of
all that like social anxiety to just
match you with a new one till you find
the right person and once you do find
the right person you can communicate in
whatever method you're most comfortable
with so that could be video chat that
could be audio phone calls it could be
texting whatever Medium you're most
comfortable with so celebrate the
progress you've already made visit
betterhelp.com toast today to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com toast betterhelp.com toast
there's really never a bad time to get
started with therapy and just start
putting yourself first and I feel like
the beginning of the year is always a
great excuse but really like let's make
this year our year you know we're
putting ourselves first girlies yes we
are all right hit me Jacks hit
shot story is the party of the Year Jeff
bezos's 60th birthday party was star
studded at his house I missed this whole
thing you I missed it too but I'm
reading the details and I don't know how
like everyone was there everything was
there was Harry and Megan there
no so it was at on Saturday night at
their house in Beverly Hills the guest
list was stacked with everyone from
Hollywood a-listers to sport sports
legends business Mogul Jay-Z Beyonce
ianka Trump Jared Kushner Sierra Russell
Wilson Oprah Winfrey Kim Kardashian
Chris Jenner haly Bieber Kendall Jenner
then also so that's like what Lauren
brought to the party then Bob Iger Bill
Gates Roger Goodell Katie Perry and
Orlando Bloom were there Katy Perry
performed Usher performed black I pe's
performed wait not Usher performing like
when he's really supposed to be in like
you know training he did probably was a
rehearsal for sure uh Paris Hilton Nikki
Hilton were there juel was there I
wonder if Kevin cner was her
date wait I'm shth honestly has done
such a good job of like making her and
Jeff like a Hollywood fixture and like
hobnobbing with with the girlies the
Kardashians a really good job a social
chair of the Bezos family part this
party is all her like the guest list is
all her and I feel like she's brought so
much to his life so much like Joy but
also like Glitz and Glam which he likes
like he's a glitzy he's a glitzy
billionaire and he likes to enjoy the
perks of his fortune that's what like
came through in elon's book like really
the differences between the two because
like they had a decent relationship but
now I don't think so anymore also Elon
wasn't there um but he's always like to
him like you know Jeff like go back to
your hot tub and he doesn't like how
like Jeff uses his blue origin company
to to take himself to space like Elon is
very much not about that
yeah no they definitely are two
different types of billionaires and like
Elon like looks and acts poor yeah he
sold all of his homes he stays at
friends houses he has a small house like
near one of the SpaceX launchpads but he
doesn't have like a a proper home so I
actually saw this thread and it happened
to be about ballerina Farm but the
general thesis applies here it's like
rich people like to cosplay poor and
poor people cosplay is Rich like it's
this weird human thing where everybody's
acting like the opposite of of what they
truly are but not you can't generalize
and say everyone Jeff Bezos doesn't like
to back poor no so Jeff Bezos is me as
Kardashian doesn't like T poor no Jeff
Bezos is exactly what I would do if I
was a rich person and actually they just
had Justin Sylvester was on the good
guys podcast oh my God this clip cracked
me up me too and I they had a big
conversation Sanchez Legend they had a
really big conversation about Lauren
Sanchez and honestly Justin was like
teaching Josh and Ben like what it's
like to be a l he's the litter and what
what what of these what it entails to be
a lady like Lauren Sanchez and it's a
lot of work it's a full-time job yeah
she's top of the Heap lady she's working
overtime and I think all of that is
evident in this party like she's given
not given him but is responsible for
their before this he was just living in
like the Pacific Northwest with his kids
and nerd working and his mom and his
friends and now he's the toast of the
town no totally she the the life cycle
of this relationship and how we got to
this point when like when we first
started talking about them the whole
National inquires like they could not
have come further I couldn't be happier
for them like I don't particularly like
Jeff Bezos the way Lauren has endeared
me to them as a couple and him as a
person like I love I stand I ship I wish
these two a lifetime of happiness TR no
I truly love and I ship and I'm so glad
that they're enjoying the fruits of
their labor also at the party there were
like a bunch of different rooms like it
started off where you walked in it was
like a repli of his first office which
was his garage and then later obnoxious
no it was like a journey through so then
like later there was like McDonald's
there he used to work at McDonald's it
was did yeah it was a celebration of his
life 60 years of Jeff that's like lowy
really impressive that he used to work
at McDonald's yeah he's an impressive
guy he's very smart he was valid
dictorian of his class I feel like
people think like Amazon is an accident
oh my God I'm so sorry I have to tell
you about what's going on
what does anybody know I think people
are going to know what I'm talking about
about Pooky talk okay there is this
couple going viral Jackie you would die
for them die di for them die for them
for them okay they're this like Southern
couple I don't know where they live her
name is Campbell and his name is jet but
nobody really knows her name because in
every video he calls her Pooky so
everybody's just like Pooky Pooky Pooky
and they are so cute and so Southern and
he's definitely like older and a little
bit nerdier and she's like this young
hot thing but he loves her so much and
he's always buying her Birkins and
whatever and then of course everybody
had to go do like a deep dive
of course normally it comes out like oh
they you know are related because
they're from the south like there was
going to be something dark you know all
they found was that jet so impressive
like valedictorian of his undergraduate
college went to and like because
everybody wonders how they're so wealthy
he's so smart went to Wharton and got
his what do you get at uh B
Masters
and law degree at the same time he it's
like and you just have to see this
couple they're so Southern they really
remind me of a couple on Southern CH I
could see them like being cast for real
and everyone's they're like blowing up
right now and everyone's talking about
them right now and you would love them
she dresses so cute and she just like
literally makes these videos to like
talk about her outfit and her husband
just talks the whole time about how he
thinks she's so beautiful that's so nice
send me her IG I will IG I wouldn't even
know how to find that like it should be
pretty easy and if she dresses cute
outfits and she has Instagram if that's
her thing it's just hard cuz like I
really if you ask me her name it takes
me like 55 minutes to remember that her
name is not
Pooky
okay oh here oh here she is okay I feel
like she's a
toaster yeah I think she is oh my God
you would love okay I'm sting to you I'm
you're GNA you should follow her also
you guys did you notice if you're
watching on YouTube I set up my new
phone oh wait we have to talk about that
we have to talk about my new phone
because I just decided yesterday and I
do want to thank Claud even though her
advice was wrong and it turns out that
you were the grandmother I know you're
living in the Stone Age I'm living in
the future with my eims you guys I just
found out yesterday we're not using SIM
cards anymore question mark and like
some of us never used SIM cards to begin
with we were always e
simming okay well that was like Grandma
of you back in the day but I was the
grandma yesterday I own it I own it no
even back in the day it was ahead of my
time that I've never had to undo a SIM
card and I just transferred everything
digitally so how did you transfer so I
took out my SIM card of my one phone
only to find out that my new phone
actually doesn't even have a slot for a
SIM card so I called Verizon and I said
um transfer my new phone and they like
hooked it up in a minute or two they
hung up on me which was beautiful but my
phone wasn't working anymore and turn on
my new phone and it was working shout
out to Verizon even though my eim should
have worked like that was wrong of you
yeah you did make it not that bad but
they rectified they rectified so I've
spent the day like logging into all of
my my apps and just like enjoying my my
new phone it's always exciting to get a
new phone you're kind of inspiring me
even though there's nothing wrong with
my phone but I do feel like the kind of
excitement was tampered because it's
been over the course of 3 weeks trying
to set up this new phone like I don't I
feel like whenever I get a new phone I'm
like clickey clickey clack hello yeah
yeah bus I'm on the phone with my seven
attorneys doing seven deals by the way I
couldn't take a call on my old phone but
on my new
yeah that Instagram comment from
Courtney Kardashian was probably one of
the larious things anybody's ever
written on the internet and that is
saying a lot yeah when someone like
accused her in the comment section of
like not being a hustler like her
sisters back when Courtney was like in
her flop era and she like didn't give a
about anything like she released
her app like six months after her
sisters did somebody like left a comment
like unemployed girly and she was like
sorry can't respond to this comment on
the attorney with my on the phone with
my attorneys negotiating seven business
deals we like sure okay yeah thou doth
protest too
much literally yeah which is why you
don't respond even though even if she
probably was I'm sure she had seven at
least brands in the works with her
attorney like you just don't respond and
give air to these things it's so true
it's so true especially when like you
know the truth you know who you are yeah
but by the way I was actually thinking
about this yesterday whatever the
opposite of flop era is Courtney is like
experiencing that obviously personally
with her like just over
joyous life you know kids pregnancy
whatever but let me tell you I was
scrolling Tik Tok yesterday Jackie every
video like all these lifestyle
influencers and they weren't ads let me
this let me that let me let me let me I
saw like f i probably saw like 15 videos
yesterday let me and they just launched
in Target I feel like Lem is on its way
to becoming like enormous I really feel
like good I hope so me too I like I feel
like now she's really on the same level
as the sisters in terms of businesses
yeah and also personal life it just goes
to show that life is very Flo fluid yeah
you think things are one way and swerve
she's in love love of her life married
who would have thought you know what
actually reminds me of this clip I just
saw I forget who it was but this guest
who was on the skinny confidential
podcast and he was like doing parenting
stuff he was basically like the first 10
years of your kids life is really like
the only time in their life where you
are everything to them like after they
turn 10 like they have friends and
you're they have other people in their
life who are like the most important to
them in that moment then of course they
get married and have their own kids and
boyfriends girlfriends best friends and
those first 10 years of your kids life
are also like the 10 years that you're
like still hustling and like still
trying to do your own thing and it's
like so sad that like you like that's
how life Works where you can't really
devote 100% of your time of those first
10 years to your kids because you have
things going on too you need to make a
living you need to do this and it's kind
of like Courtney did the well actually
she had kids before when she was young
too maybe not but I I felt like maybe
that clip was relevant maybe it's not no
I think it is relevant I think what you
said that she was in her flop ERA with
the apps like those were those were the
first 10 years of her kid life so yeah
she didn't give a about the apps
that went nowhere and instead she was
focused on parenting like in hindsight
she's winning thank you yes my point was
correct yes she did like exactly what
that clip said yeah as you and the thing
is you get those 10 solid years where
you are everything and like be there as
much as you can it's it's a I mean most
of us are working but as much as you can
like be there no so for someone like
Courtney who obviously like working is a
choice not a requirement
honestly she kind of killed it yeah she
kind of killed it like her kids are
grown now she was such like a
hardcore maybe even like a little nuts
mom you know like so involved and now
her kids are grown and she's like having
success and she's fell in love again
like I don't know it's like kind of
everything yeah no it's it's kind of
it's a fairy tale it's a fairy tale yeah
are you ready for our next story what
number is it two oh yeah Stacey explains
why she will not be on the Vander pump
rules spin-off show called The Valley so
we didn't even discuss this but a new
show is coming to Bravo called the
valley and it is about like Valley
Suburban life starring Jackson Britney
and a few new faces and also Christen
Dodie so I think people always expected
a show like this would come from the
cast members that had settled down in
the valley and they expected that Stacey
would be on it but she is explaining why
she's not on it and she said it's not
Bravo's fault that's that she's not on
it once this idea was brought up and
they were like okay we're going to film
a Sizzle with all the people that would
be on it every fiber of my being voted
no she
said um when Jeff Lewis asked her she
was on Jeff Lewis's show she said asked
why she felt so strongly about not
appearing on Bravo again she said there
were a lot of different reasons first of
all it wouldn't be a reflection of what
my reality is because it's just not my
group of friends and she said I'm
friendly with some of them I'm
acquainted with some of them and some of
the new ones too I that I think are are
lovely but it's not my crew then Jeff
Lewis said that she might become closer
to them if she filmed with them and she
argued that she doesn't want to have to
go and do things that she normally
wouldn't do she said I don't want to
disr disrupt the life that I have right
now because I really like my life right
now yeah I never really thought there
have been rumors about this show and
everybody like somehow knew it was going
to be called like Valley Village rumors
about Jack Britney and Christen making a
return in some way of a spin-off I don't
think anybody really I wasn't thinking
Stacey was going to be a part of it
mostly because she doesn't live in the
valley oh not even mostly cuz she
doesn't live in the valley but I feel
like reality TV is such a hard thing to
like extricate yourself from because
it's just like this this beast and it's
a cycle and you need it and you depend
on it and then when you're Thrust out
from it like it might take you a while
but like once you got on your feet it I
can't imagine the I process of going
back into it especially once you've like
seen how toxic it could be like what
yeah the dark side and I just feel like
now that she's out she's not going back
in and she's out and she's on her feet
and she's doing well and she has so many
things going for her she does not need
reality TV at all like don't do it and
it's almost better that she was thrust
out cuz I think making the decision to
leave a show that's successful but also
toxic is probably really hard CU you're
making a lot of money and so obviously
at the time when she was fired it was
really not ideal and there was like a
lot of you know scandals going on at the
time but I think probably now in
hindsight she really got into a Groove
where her podcast is really successful
she's a really successful patreon she's
like a really successful influencer
she's a very devoted mom and I think
when you're a mom and I'm sure you know
this better than me it's like like good
is good why ruin a good thing you know
like I she makes a very good living I'm
sure she gets to be home with her
kids why throw yourself back into that
sort of toxicity yeah she's her own boss
and also making the decision to go back
to reality TV is like a different sort
of decision when you have kids cuz when
it's just you and you know the Beast and
she's like she's a pro she she could I
want to say though I could see Stacey
going back to reality TV like I don't
think she's necessarily done yet but
she's coming at it now from like a
position of privilege where she knows
what she's bringing she doesn't have to
be like on an ensemble show she doesn't
have to eat and she doesn't have to
just be on any show that wants her like
I agree if the right situation came to
her she might do it she's not like
against reality T TV forever but she
doesn't need it she's not like been
waiting to get back on TV she if the
right opportunity presents itself she
would consider it I'm sure she
considered this heavily and then voted
no I think also a lot of it has to do
with money and so when you have Ventures
like she wrote another book it was
another New York Times bestseller she
did a big podcast tour when you're off
reality and you have a hard time
monetizing whatever it is that you're
doing whether it's a podcast it's very
hard to get people to listen to you like
it's not as easy as everybody thinks and
there are a lot of people former vaner
pump rols or just former reality TV show
people in general who don't make the
same amount of money afterwards
sometimes very rarely you end up making
more Hannah burner I feel like she's the
best example um but she's the exception
not the rule yeah so more often than not
whenever anybody gets an opportunity to
go back they're going to do it and
that's why these shows like Traders or
they're so popular because there's
really not a huge career after reality
TV for everyone some people not for
everyone yeah right agreed also reality
TV brings so many eyeballs and so many
positive things but it also opens you up
again yep for Scandal yep and once
you've been through it like you don't
you want to avoid electively choose oh
let me try that again yeah
no I I I was not shocked she was not on
the show I was not expecting to see her
and I I agree it was probably the right
decision for her yeah are you ready for
our next story are you ready kids a I
tury I can't hear
you our next story White Lotus star Tom
Hollander says he accidentally received
Tom Holland's seven figures of Ven
Avengers bonus check so Tom Hollander
who is not Tom Holland said he
accidentally received Tom Holland's
bonus check for an Avengers film he
revealed on Late Night with Seth Meers
that he often gets mistaken for Tom
Holland in nonvisual context because the
White Lotus star is 56 and Tom Holland
is 27 including in the accounts
Department of his agency which also
briefly represented Tom Holland he said
I went to see my friend who was doing
theater in England I sat smugly in the
audience just having done a BBC show for
$30,000 he said he checked his email
during the interval and that's when he
saw a message from the agency saying
that were that they were sending his
first box office bonus for the Avengers
the actor said he thought to himself I
don't think I'm in The Avengers but then
he proceeded to open the email it was an
astonishing amount of money it was not
his salary it was his first box office
bonus not the whole box office bonus the
first one and it was more money than I'd
ever seen it was a seven figure sum so
seven figures could be anywhere from 1
to 9 million yeah 9 million 9
,99 yeah uh he said that Tom hullen was
only 20 or something in his age so his
feeling of smugness in the show that he
was at uh during the first half uh
disappeared very quickly he said but
that show biz it's up it's down it's
hero it's zero well I just want to say
that's really so crazy first of all I
didn't Tom Hollander if you don't know
him because I didn't know him either he
plays the like the gay in charge who's
trying to kill uh what's her name
spoiler alert Jennifer coolage Jennifer
kage these gays they're trying to kill
me he's like the one in charge um and
when I was reading this headline I was
so confused because when I saw Tom
Hollander I just assumed it was Zena's
boyfriend I did not know that was his
name so I understand how this mix-up
could be like possible but Loki is
unacceptable like what you get paid is
so personal like and not only that this
guy then going on Seth Meers is like
telling the story like I wonder if he
had Tom Holland's approval I'm sure he
didn't um this is like Loki just nuts
and a huge invasion of Tom Holland's
privacy yeah but Tom Holland is in the
Avengers he's Spider-Man and yeah I
assume he makes millions of dollars so
it's not in Congress seven figures I
thought it would be more it was just the
first bonus and it wasn't his salary
right right you get paid to do a movie
and then after that's crazy like you
just open your email couple Mill today
that's
insane and he's so lowkey
Tom Holland yeah he like doesn't really
do pressor interviews and he he's not
really a celebrity like I don't watch
his movies therefore I do not know him
aside from Zend his boyfriend I know and
I don't even think he has an
Instagram actually he might but it's
like promotional you know it's like for
work because he's a working actor yeah
do you think paid like Kevin Hart to
promote on his
Instagram oh he does I'm so sorry he has
66 million
followers what does he post for like
very artsy work stuff critic's choice
the brothers trust it's all like high
quality content it's Promotional and a
little artistic oh and of course
philanthropic he's at a puppy facility
here oh that's sweet it's a pretty good
Instagram I'm not going to lie it's not
bad it's got a mix of everything I feel
like it's run by like an agency like
this is classic serus actor Instagram
with also Commercial Success yeah yeah
he's also like one of those actors who's
not afraid to look ugly like in half
those pictures he looked ugly when I
know he's like a handsome man you know
he posted a picture of Zena I always
thought they were super private like
that they've never even acknowledged
that they're dating but he posted a
picture of just her uh congratulating
her for her award at cfda Fashion Awards
they have been together for years yeah
and I think only in the last two maybe
one year they've been like more public
about but they still are not even like
very they don't walk red carpets really
together I guess like this probably made
a lot of 11 million likes I'm sure
people were freaking that he posted this
when he posted it but because like again
I don't know Tom Holland like I didn't
pay attention
yeah this is just one of those things
where Jackie and I being really removed
from the uh Universe of Marvel and DC
Comics like this is just not our sort of
celebrity you want to know why tury
because we're too
girly we are so feminine we're so
feminine we don't know who these
superheroes are but we're such a unique
breed of females let me tell you why
because we don't know anything about
Marvel or DC but we also don't didn't
like cry over the Barbie movie so what
does that make us where does that leave
us you know what we are
toasters and I just want to say I know
this is going to be a really polarizing
thing to say and I have to stop talking
about the Barbie movie because I keep
complaining about like people being mad
at what I'm saying and I keep bringing
it up but Hillary Clinton released a
statement about Greta Gerwig and Margot
Robbie not being nominated for Oscars
and I feel as though officially as a
nation we have lost the plot and I think
the Barbie rhetoric and polarization of
Barbie has officially as of as of of
yesterday as of the minute Hillary
Clinton sent that tweet with that
statement and she made a graphic we took
it too far we girl bossed too close to
the Sun for real no one's going to take
us seriously as a gender now seriously
thanks Hillary no the cringe was off the
charts cringe it was far too much yeah
and I posted like something about Barbie
movie on my close friends and like not
like every influencer being like wait no
me too like what is with people in the
Barbie movie like I didn't think it was
so great it's like we're literally
living under communist rule we can't say
that we don't like the Barbie movie Kim
Jong Barbie Kim Jong Barbie Jong-un
Barbie
Jong you think un is oier than ill unagi
what's that from Friends classic you
could just say pure nonsense and then
just tell me it's from friends and be
like oh yeah classic yeah Jackie GBA
friends yeah it is but that's actually
from friends I didn't just make it up
it's Ross's and Rachel's daughter's
first word GBA and they're like that's
not a word and then he looks it up and
it's like a particular type of like
molecule and you know Ross is really
into s like I literally the hate a
scientist the hate I have in my heart
for what you're describing right
now um but that is funny he's a
scientist but up until that that was not
funny it wasn't funny but though I do
usually like friends through your
summarizations you didn't let by the way
yesterday I was wanting to cite a
friend's reference and you totally cut
me off and I never got back to it no
leave it there leave it in the dust
let's get into our fourth story no let's
not let's not is this nice
now you're back to cursing I think the
kids are asleep you can curse again
mother no not in front of the
ad the rest of today's episode is
brought to you by signos the CDC
estimates that there are approximately
96 million American adults that have
pre-diabetes and of those with
pre-diabetes more than 80% don't know
that they have it so a healthy weight
allows insulin to work more efficiently
and can help you keep regular blood
sugars within a normal range a healthy
diet and regular exercise are the best
ways to help bring your blood sugar
levels back to a healthy range and
signos can help you Short Circuit the
cycle by using data directly from your
body to design a weight loss plan that's
unique to your lifestyle signos is the
only company that combines a CGM which
is a continuous glucose monitor with an
aid driven app to deliver real-time
glucose monitoring for Optimal Health
and weight management with signos you
can literally see which foods cause your
blood sugar to spike above reasonable
levels and get realtime alerts to do a
bit of exercise to bring them back back
down so you can learn the difference
between stress eating and physical
hunger you can better manage your energy
throughout the day and you can sleep
better at night and you'll be able to
meet your weight loss and health goals
with unique to you data signosis unique
to you program for weight loss is backed
by a growing field of scientific
research and scientists that point to
stable glucose as a key part of overall
health signos removes the guesswork of
weight loss and provides you with the
tools and knowledge that you need to
develop healthier habits it combines
glucose data from the CGM or the
continuous glucose monitor with an aid
driven app to deliver real real time
glucose insights for Optimal Health and
weight management right now signos has
an offer exclusive for our listeners go
to sos.com
sns.com and get 20% off select Plans by
using Code toast that's sos.com code
toast to get 20% off select plans today
thank you you're welcome our next
story that's beautiful maybe you should
perform at Coachella because they're
seeing the slowest tickets sales in a
decade so Coachella lineup was announced
last week in past years the tickets have
sold out in a matter of minutes it is
now 5 days later and tickets are still
on sale it turns out people aren't all
that interested in Coachella this year
this year marks the slowest ticket sales
in a decade this is according to SFGate
which cites some troubling stats for
golden voice and Co long story short
passes for this year's Coachella just
aren't selling like they used to they're
very much still up for grabs 5 days
after hitting the market whereas in the
past it would sell out in minutes
interesting this site lets people
purchase up to eight tickets this year
compared to only two in previous years
so it looks as though Festival
organizers are practically begging
people to splash some cash on them at
least that's how it feels anyway
according to TMZ though they've never
had this issue before fans famously
waited hours in Virtual cues to get
their hands on Covetous wristbands in
Years Gone by this is strange cuz Kella
tickets are usually a hot commodity in
out in minutes so so I think it's
layered what's the reason for the season
as a reminder the headliners are Lana
Del Rey Tyler the Creator doic cat and
no doubt which I think is a good lineup
I I don't think it's a good lineup it's
a good lineup however Coachella got
themselves into this pattern where the
last like five years there has been like
a major major star like we've had Lady
Gaga we've had Beyonce we've had Justin
Bieber we've had Billy ish we've had the
weekend we've had Styles like they have
made it into a Super Bowl of sorts and
they don't have that type of performer
this year you don't think L and Del Ray
is that performer no with a cult
following who would follow around the
world for her it's a cult following it's
very Niche it's not on the radio you
know it's not commercial also but I do
want to say I still think the lineup's
pretty good I think another huge Factor
as to why people aren't buying tickets
that I don't think anybody's talking
about is like we're in a economic crisis
like it's these tickets are really
expensive and the whole journey is
expensive it's not only the tickets it's
the renting of the house it's the
outfits Coachella is this like aair it's
not just a music festival where you wear
a pair of denim shorts and no makeup and
you just like sweat and cry it's not
Woodstock it's an event it requires if
you're going to go and do it up it
requires a lot of money outside of the
actual ticket airfare hotel lodging
things like that and it's thousands of
dollars and not everyone can do that
right now so I think it's a combination
I would love to know what was Coachella
going on in like 2008 what were ticket
sales like then you know yeah it's I
think it was going on in it was going on
in 2008 it's been around for a while but
it didn't become like thisp culture sort
of thing it was really an indie music
festival for a long time um and not what
it is right now so tur's blaming the
economy and I do think that is a good I
think it's a factor it's not everything
it's definitely a factor but I also
think that maybe
Coachella you know all good things must
come to an end and maybe this new
younger generation like isn't as into f
Festival as the Millennials are maybe
they just want to see like their one
performer I don't know I'm just guessing
but seriously like all good things must
come to an end and maybe this is like
the slowing down of Coachella because
the people who can go are not into it
wow I didn't even think that like that's
a good take I it didn't cross my mind
that like Coachella is over party it's
like it's not cool anymore like it's on
its way out yeah and I do think it's
very much like a millennial it is thing
and like the Millennials are having kids
and and doing different things or or
maybe just like don't want to go see DOA
cat because she's for Gen ZZ but the Gen
zers don't want to go to Coachella
because it's like a millennial Relic
honestly you're making fire
points thank you la like that thing you
just said that like the lineup is now
geared towards gen Z j z doesn't want to
be associated with Coachella because and
also you have to be 21 to go to
Coachella actually you might have to be
18 but still yeah I know what you're
saying that's a fire Point fire yes so I
feel like there's looking fire today a
little bit of a
gap
yeah and I don't and like L let
everybody who thought it was going to be
Taylor we would this conversation of
course but that's the thing I'd like the
if your if your ticket sales are
predicated on how big of a star you can
get that's like a hamster wheel you're
never going to be able to keep up with
that no and it definitely gets away from
the original Mission of Coachella where
people were going regardless of the
headliners they were trusting that the
music would be good because it was like
curated by Indie music experts and now
it's it's totally dependent on the
headliner it's Jingle Ball now it's
Jingle Ball and when we went like for
the first time a while ago it was still
very much like Indie Vibes but Lady Gaga
was the headliner and it was like kind
of crazy because everything else was
like Tam and Paula the you know Menendez
brother no Martinez not the Menendez
brothers I hope the Martinez Brothers it
was very people you've never heard of
and Lady Gaga was like kind of crazy and
that's why we went we were like all
right we'll go to see a Lady Gaga
concert and they just really leaned into
that which is fine it's very much a
giving Jingle Ball these days yeah but
then it's also going to give Willie
neilly yeah it's giving like what is
coachella's aesthetic now Coachella is
having an identity crisis yes but you
know who's not stage coach tickets
higher sales than ever right I was
wondering how this would compare to
Stage Coach because country fans aren't
willy-nilly but literally like pop music
and what's on the
radio no no one person through their
entire life is really going to be
listening to the same radio station
their entire life with the hits they're
going to eventually like I'm listening
to the pulse now I'm not going to lie oh
wow she's pulsing z00 or shall I say y
100 it's not always for me now because
it's TI to music I now want to go listen
to what's considered the classics yeah I
feel that so the pulse it is yeah
I I haven't heard any KT I haven't heard
anything about um stage coach tickets
but I have to imagine they're not
experiencing this problem Oh I thought
you sounded like an expert when you said
highest ticket sales in history oh no no
no but I didn't hear anything and I like
the last time I was there it was packed
to the brim well it's always going to be
packed and the headliners weren't even
amazing and this year they're amazing
it's Morgan Wallen this year I'm sure
I'm sure they're G you can't even get
Morgan Wild tickets like in your town so
yeah we're going to Coachella for him
and I'm pretty sure they released the
tickets and I'm pretty sure you can't
get
them Stage Coach festival.com
join waight list Stage Coach 2024 is
sold out okay but how long did it take
Eric Church Miranda Lambert Morgan
Wallen those are the headliners and then
second line post
Malone jelly roll Nickelback dipo I'm
sure you're 100% right but Coachella
tickets will sell out it's just been 5
days and they haven't how long did stage
coach tickets take to sell out this
website says it's the biggest on sale in
history Stage Coach 2024 is officially
sold out you have made history thank you
for joining us on this journey join the
wait list to be notified if any passes
become available so you were right the
biggest in history yep and where's the
article on that let me look at
news
no but good for
them okay are you ready for our next
story it's our fifth and final yeah and
I need to shout out to Lauren Elizabeth
cuz she sent it my way and she said this
is giving Fifth and vinyl energy oh
what' she say Peta is calling to replace
beloved Groundhogs Day star Paton Phil
with a gold coin so Peta wants to canel
Peta is making news twice they're going
viral for being really insensitive not
the University of Georgia you know go
dogs had they had like a real life
mascot dog this English Bulldog um and
he passed away and English Bulldogs like
they don't encourage breeding English
Bulldogs because they have a lot of
health issues they literally can't
breathe um and so they like posted a
graphic that he died and being like
maybe this will teach you to stop
breeding like and it was like really
insensitive yeah like read the room
we're grieving no and you're supposed to
be like an organization that Advocates
on behalf of animals so like you using
the death of an animal to be like snarky
people were really upset in defense of
the dog yeah no so they're doing that
but they're also trying to cancel patani
fil Peta wants to replace Phil the
Beloved groundhog that is used to
forecast weather during the annual
Groundhog Day celebration in
Pennsylvania they want to replace him
with a gold coin the group said this
week Peter wrote an open letter on
Monday to the patani groundout club in
Pennsylvania in which they encouraged
its president to remove the animal from
the celebration should he formally
retire Phil and take him to a sanctuary
then Peta would present the group with a
giant coin they said in the letter
beyond a shadow of a doubt a Groundhog's
weather prediction is no more accurate
than flipping a coin of for de
he is not a meteorologist and deserves
better than to be exploited every year
for tourism
money okay I just want to say like Peta
is dying on the wrong Hill there are so
many more worthy animal causes and I
think when it comes to like old school
Traditions that involve animals like we
have to take it Case by case like I
think a really old school tradition like
here in New York is the horse and
carriage rides in the city and like I
personally feel like those should not be
allowed anymore like I think we've
evolved past that as a society patani
Phil having to work one day he'll be
fine I'm sure he's treated like a king I
sure the horses in Central Park are
looking at punksatony Phil as like this
privileged snob and like he's getting
attention the attention of peta peta
should be using their platform for
bigger and better things I'm sorry this
is a waste or what about like the dogs
that were shot dead by Hamas on October
7th as they invaded Israel like where's
Peta on that love the point you're
bringing up there too love that Peta can
right off yeah how I this is an
abuse of their
platform Paton Phil doesn't hurt anybody
he probably lives this lavish life
nobody talks to him except for one day
he has to work one day and all he has to
do is like be put in a box he's fine
leave him alone this is a harmless
tradition and I'm a big Advocate on
behalf of animals like whenever I see
something even when I see a dog you know
me when I see a dog in a movie it
bothers me I think Phil is fine he's
fine Phil is fine and like Why Try emplo
Phil he has a job he makes a living he
has a nice life and you want to fire him
you want to take his job away hog with
no job and no and Phil has a family to
support wrong wrong the only if they
wanted to make a good argument I would
say the argument would be like how about
we stop dropping the
groundhogs yeah and that's a human error
thing you know like Bill DeBlasio
dropped a groundhog correct yes he did
where was Peta then
cuz that ain't right it's what we like
to call animal abuse I would not want to
hold a groundhog personally like it's
they're kind of like of the Rat elk rat
elk yes and I think perhaps why our
reaction to this story like is so we
don't give a is because it's
literally a
rat and like you're not going to find me
like horses are these beautiful
smart un unbelievable creatures you know
I don't feel that way about a groundhog
a groundhog is to me like a beaver yeah
like you get a what does that movie
catty Shack Shack they got groundhogs in
the garden and it's like a problem you
know yeah they're pests no it's like a
Pome yeah it's a pest literally so sorry
you're not going to find me like I love
animals but like I'm going to put a
mouse trap down you know I'm human right
you got to draw the line somewhere I'm
sorry no I think I stand with Phil and
the puat only Phil the patani groundhogs
Association I think what you're doing is
totally fine and it's a nice one of
those like nice archaic Traditions that
like means nothing but it's cute yeah no
like we know the weather is not
listening to Phil you know mother nature
and Phil do not communicate and it's
like a fun tradition for kids it's so
dumb and harmless I can't even believe
we're having this conversation I agree
so officially we stand with Phil yeah if
you want to know where the toast stands
it's firmly with Phil it's usually
against Peta whatever they're yapping on
about no I feel like usually I'm with
Peta like I stand with like their cause
their mission their Reem te is good but
I feel like in practice they're always
directing their efforts at the worst
things and in the worst ways too so I
feel okay I think that their choice of
campaigns is not always the best like
the things they go after but I do think
they get a bad rap because I think there
are like people who love maybe don't
work for Pea in official capacity who do
like insane stunts on behalf of pea but
I actually I don't think those people
work for pea I have to I people who
throw paint yes at fashion shows right
those don't come from Peta on high I
don't think they're hired you know
staffers from Peta I think they're just
like real
Peta Felix well no Peta files yeah
right but not in the pedophilic sense in
the in the pet fix send yeah like how
you're a Franco File you're a Peta file
but not having to do with children I
just feel like Peta has gotten really
far away from their mission at times and
and that they use their platform and
like their brand name as a more of like
a political football than to actually
care for animals all animals all the
time I agree with you from like a public
POV I think they have like in recent
years started to come off a little nuts
but I do imagine as an organization they
still do really good work like behind
the scenes things we don't know about
right but why is the good work behind
the scenes and the Nutty work out front
that is a question for the pr director
of PETA and it's a good one yeah it's a
good question thank you I feel like they
all just like sat around in a room like
what's going to be our next thing and
it's like Phil the past 5 years like we
have seen the radicalization of pea I
completely agree that's what I'm saying
we need a fresh pea like that really I
mean that's like the under pump dogs I
think that they are really cause
driven yes the under pump dogs is a new
pea like how we all learned about that
dog Festival in China like we learned
about that from Vander pump rules yeah
Vander pump rules Vanderpump dogs is a
Nita I love
that love it even though Vanderpump dogs
like only does dogs whereas I was just
about to say that but like they don't I
feel like they do other animals it's
just called Vander pump dogs and so they
they're ready for a re I'm sorry I think
they have rebranded to Vander pump
pets but does that just mean like
domestic animals I don't know maybe
they're clearly working through what
we're working through because they're
evolving and I think it's great
yeah so those were the fast five stories
and that is unfortunately our show which
is so sad but what's not sad is merch is
dropping tomorrow so these sweat sets
that Jackie and I are wearing just a
reminder 10: a.m. eastern time tomorrow
Friday January 26th at shop toast
merch.com we will put links everywhere
if you want this sweat set don't worry
we're going to make sure you get it
check our Instagram Stories the toes
Jackson CLA so that you could see
everything that's dropping tomorrow we
will we had a photo shoot we had a photo
shoot and we'll have blanks that you
could see just like the products so you
can plan your buy thank you guys so much
for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the fast life stories that you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so that's Spotify iTunes
Stitcher public radio ihart radio cast
boox all the places wherever you listen
to podcast find us the toast Le five
star you bet beautiful stunning and
wickedly talented we are hope you guys
have an AM amazing day and we'll see you
tomorrow bye love you
bye